بعد أكثر من عامين على انسحاب الولايات المتحدة
من الاتفاق النووي الإيراني ، فإن
طهران الآن تنتهك صراحة تلك الصفقة
مع استئناف تخصيب اليوران
إلى 20 أعلى بكثير من الحد المتفق عليه
في الصفقة
، أقر البرلمان الإيراني
الشهر الماضي قانونًا لتعزيز التخصيب
أيضًا لمنع  أنت في عمليات التفتيش إذا
لم يتم رفع العقوبات
تأتي أيضًا بعد عام واحد من مقتل
الجنرال الإيراني قاسم سليماني ،
استولت إيران بشكل منفصل على
ناقلة النفط التي تحمل علم
كوريا الجنوبية لعمان بدعوى أنها تلوث مياه الخليج
، وأرسلت كوريا الجنوبية مدمرة إلى مضيق
هرمز والدبلوماسية
ورد
أن الجهود جارية لمحاولة تأمين الإفراج عن
الناقلة وطاقمها على
الهواء مباشرة مع مراسل دولي رفيع المستوى
سام كيلي في القدس
مع المزيد حول هذا
الأمر ، لذا فهم يتحدثون عن
الجهود الدبلوماسية لمحاولة
حل هذه المشكلة
ولكن  ثم لديك هذا أيضا أه
تعرف أن العملية العسكرية جارية مع
القوات
وأه تعرف السفن يتم إرسالها إلى منطقة
الريجيو  n um هو هذا فقط مايك
لدعم الدبلوماسية
أعتقد أن الإجابة المختصرة أن جون هو بالتأكيد
عبارة عن قارب مدفعي أو دبلوماسية حاملة طائرات
قادمة من
الولايات المتحدة التي أمرت
مجموعة حاملة الطائرات نيميتز
بالعودة إلى قاعدة الوطن هذا
الأمر  أُلغي قيل الآن
أن يبقى
كامنًا في المنطقة لتعزيز
أه التهديدات بصراحة من الولايات المتحدة
أه وأيضًا من إسرائيل بأن
إيران لن يُسمح لها في
نظرهم بتطوير قدرة أسلحة نووية
الآن هذا الإعلان الأخير
من إيران أثار  رئيس
الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ليقول تكرار هذا
التهديد والتهديد ليس له قوة أه خاصة
ورائه من حيث أنهم لم
يكشفوا عما سيفعلونه إذا
وصلوا إلى المسرح عندما
قرروا أن إيران
لديها قدرة نووية  لكنها قصة الرعب المطلقة
أه للدولة اليهودية
وكابوس أه
إستراتيجي للمنطقة ربما لهذا السبب أه
تلك السعودية وقطر
بدأوا في وضع خلافاتهم
الشديدة جانبًا ، وسيحضر القطريون لأول مرة
منذ عدة سنوات اجتماع
مجلس التعاون الخليجي
في المملكة العربية السعودية اليوم بعد
أن انتهى السعوديون أو وافقوا على فتح
حدودهم جواً وبراً وفي  من البحر
إلى القطريين بالطبع ، هاتان الدولتان
اللتان تطلان عبر الخليج العربي أو
الخليج الفارسي تجاه
إيران قلقان للغاية بشأن هذه
التوترات الإقليمية التي تتصاعد بشكل دوري
وتتصاعد نتيجة
انسحاب الولايات المتحدة إلى حد كبير
كما ذكرت هناك جون.  من
ما يسمى بـ jcpoa الصفقة النووية التي
كان من
المفترض أن تجعل الإيرانيين
ينحون برنامجهم النووي
مقابل رفع العقوبات منذ أن
تركت الإدارة الرابحة
ذلك وذهبت لشن حملة من
الضغط الأقصى رأينا
زيادة في  التوترات وكما أشرت بحق ، فإن
هذا قريب جدًا
من ذكرى مقتل سليماني الجنرال
سول  إيماني
قائد فيلق كودز التابع للحرس الثوري الإيراني
الذي كان مسؤولاً عما قد يصفه
الأمريكيون والإسرائيليون وآخرون
بأنه عمليات إيران المزعزعة للاستقرار
في المنطقة على وجه الخصوص
سوريا والعراق ولكن أيضًا بالطبع في اليمن
لذلك
لم يحدث أي من تلك التوترات.  لقد سقطت من
خلال الإدارة الرابحة ،
هناك شعور هنا بأن
الجميع يحبس أنفاسهم حتى
تتمكن إدارة بايدن من العودة إلى
السلطة وربما تهدئة التصعيد والعودة إلى
الدبلوماسية الحقيقية ، لكن الأمور متوترة جدًا في الوقت الحالي